la forêt de chaux c'est là que les
enquêteurs désormais recherches le corps
de l'étudiante japonaise selon le
journal le parisien
le gps du véhicule loué par son
meurtrier présumé aurait ciblé cette
zone l'exploitation des données de
l'instrument devrait permettre en partie
de retracer le parcours de cet homme
dans la région au chili où l'ex petit
ami de naomi se trouvait encore la
semaine dernière
l'étau semble se resserrer si l'homme
est introuvable
la justice chilienne vient d'annoncer
qu'elle allait collaborer avec la france
le mandat d'arrêt international lancé
contre ce professeur assistant devrait
donc rapidement aboutir tout le monde
l'espère quant aux médias japonais très
nombreux à besançon ils continuent eux
aussi leurs investigations